tenemos esta caja vacía y tenemos esta
etapa que podemos poner encima de la
caja vacía y digamos que no hay
resistencia así que si le doy cierto
empujoncito a esta etapa se va a mover
cierta distancia con cierta velocidad
constante y digamos que no hay
resistencia al aire ninguna fuerza que
haga resistencia ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es llenar esta caja con un fluido
hasta el tope digamos que es agua lo
llenamos hasta el tope y lo que sucede
cuando ponemos esta tapa encima es que
si queremos deslizarla le vamos a dar un
empujón pero va a irse más lento y se va
a detener si le damos otro empujón se va
a mover un poquito va a ir más lento y
se va a detener el hecho de que aquí
tengamos un fluido va a ser que esto se
resista al movimiento y esto es debido a
que el fluido es viscoso qué significa
esto significa que cuando esta etapa se
está moviendo por encima el hecho de que
el fluido esté
contacto con la tapa va a hacer que esta
primera capa de líquido se mueva con la
tapa a la velocidad de la tapa hay
fuerzas de adhesión entre el fluido y la
tapa a un nivel molecular cuando muevo
la tapa en el fluido también se mueve
con esta y resiste el movimiento pero
aún peor cuando jalamos esta capa
superior la capa que está abajo también
se va a mover aunque un poco menos y
esta segunda capa va a hacer que la capa
que está abajo de ella se mueva también
aunque un poquito menos y esto continúa
así de manera que nos queda un gradiente
de velocidad que es el hombre
sofisticado de este efecto significa que
la velocidad de este fluido va a ir
disminuyendo cada vez más hasta que
lleguemos al fondo aquí abajo el fluido
va a estar en contacto con la superficie
inferior y esta superficie de abajo no
se está moviendo por lo que el fluido
que se encuentra en el fondo no se va a
mover
es por eso que cuando empujamos esta
etapa va a ir más despacio y se va a
detener ya que está arrastrando al
fluido que está debajo de ella y si la
tapa ejerce una fuerza sobre el fluido
hacia la derecha el fluido va a ejercer
una fuerza sobre la tapa pero hacia la
izquierda esto se debe a la tercera ley
de newton y le vamos a llamar a esta
fuerza la fuerza de viscosidad fb de que
depende esta fb de que depende esta
fuerza de viscosidad una cosa de la que
depende es el área de contacto no es el
área total de la tapa solamente aquella
área que está en contacto con el fluido
si nos imaginamos las dimensiones de
esta caja va a ser algo más o menos así
y esta es el área de la que depende la
fuerza de viscosidad y esta fuerza es
proporcional a esta área mientras más
grande sea el área más fluido estaremos
arrastrando con ella y será más grande
la fuerza de viscosidad otra cosa de la
que depende es la velocidad o rapidez
con la que estamos empujando o jalando
la tapa mientras más rápido esté jalando
esta etapa la fuerza de viscosidad será
más grande en sentido opuesto así que la
fuerza de viscosidad es proporcional a
la velocidad o rapidez con la que
movemos la tapa y a su vez es
inversamente proporcional a la
profundidad del fluido vamos a llamarlo
de y depende de una cosa más depende de
la viscosidad del fluido de hecho ese es
el factor más importante de toda esta
fórmula esta le vamos a llamar al
coeficiente de viscosidad del fluido
este número nos dice que tan viscoso o
denso o espeso es este fluido que tanto
se resiste al flujo para darles una idea
sobre el coeficiente de viscosidad la
miel y otros jarabes tendrán un
coeficiente de viscosidad grande el agua
tendrá un coeficiente de viscosidad más
pequeño y los gases tendrán un
coeficiente de viscosidad muy pequeña
cuáles son las unidades del coeficiente
de viscosidad vamos a deducir las si
despejamos eta nos va a quedar la fuerza
de viscosidad dividida entre el área
multiplicada por la profundidad de y
dividida entre la velocidad que unidades
hay aquí las unidades de las fuerzas son
newtons la unidad de la distancia es
metros la unidad del área es metros
cuadrados y la velocidad o rapidez es
metros sobre segundo pero como lo tengo
en el denominador los segundos los voy a
pasar al número
y si simplificó me va a quedar que
canceló estos metros
las unidades de la viscosidad son
newtons sobre metro al cuadrado por
segundo pero el newton sobre metro al
cuadrado es un pascal así que esto es
pascal por segundo estas unidades son un
poco extrañas pero son las unidades de
eta el coeficiente de viscosidad es una
presión por unidad de tiempo
pascal por segundo algunas personas usan
la unidad point y un point es igual a un
décimo de pascal por segundo o en otras
palabras 10 pues ya podemos abreviar con
la letra p mayúscula son iguales a un
pascal por segundo o lo que es lo mismo
10 pascales son iguales a un pascal por
segundo frecuentemente escuchamos de
esta unidad pues como la unidad del
coeficiente de viscosidad cuáles son
algunos ejemplos de valores reales de
viscosidad bueno la viscosidad del agua
que está a cero grados celsius no está
congelada pero
tiene esa temperatura de cero grados
celsius tiene 1.8 mil y pascal es por
segundo o lo que es lo mismo un sentí
pois porque un point ya es una décima
parte de un pascal por segundo así que
um sentí pois es igual a un 1000 y
pascal por segundo
en este caso 1.8 sentí pois
o el agua a 20 grados celsius tendrá un
coeficiente de viscosidad de 1.0 mili
pascal es por segundo o senti pois y
como pueden ver la viscosidad depende en
gran medida de la temperatura del fluido
mientras más frío esté este fluido
tendrá un mayor coeficiente de
viscosidad es por eso que si encendemos
nuestro auto cuando hace mucho frío el
aceite que tiene el auto va a estar más
viscoso lo que nos va a dificultar el
encender el auto la sangre tiene una
viscosidad típica de 3 a 4 mil y pascal
es por segundo o sentí pois y el aceite
de motor puede tener un coeficiente de
viscosidad de alrededor de 200 sentí
pois los gases tienen una viscosidad muy
pequeña por ejemplo el aire tiene una
viscosidad de aproximadamente 0 punto
cero 18 sentí pois es importante saber
que si un fluido sigue
regla para la fuerza de viscosidad y el
coeficiente de viscosidad no depende de
la velocidad a la cual se está moviendo
este fluido oa la cual estamos moviendo
la tapa del contenedor si este
coeficiente no depende de esto le
llamaremos a esto un fluído newtoniano
pero si el coeficiente de viscosidad si
depende de la velocidad con la cual se
mueve el fluido o se mueve la tapa que
cubre el contenedor entonces será un
fluido no newtoniano si este coeficiente
de viscosidad permanece igual sin
importar cuál sea la velocidad del
fluido o de la tapa es un fluido
newtoniana en caso contrario es un
fluido no newtoniano y ustedes pueden
estar pensando oye esto es un poco
irreal cuantas veces voy a tener yo que
estar empujando una tapa que está sobre
un contenedor lleno de líquido pero esto
es solo una forma práctica de determinar
la viscosidad una vez que ya conocemos
la viscosidad podemos aplicar este
número este número es una constante del
fluido en cualquier punto de este fluido
podremos determinar con este número cuál
será la tasa del flujo vamos a quitar
todo esto de aquí e imaginemos que
tenemos un tubo o tubería estacionario
tiene un fluido que pasa
de él a lo mejor es una avena o una
arteria y está pasando sangre por está y
cómo está estacionario tanto la parte
superior como inferior van a estar sin
moverse por lo que el fluido que está
arriba y abajo realmente no va a estar
moviéndose sin embargo el fluido que
está en el medio se va a estar moviendo
con mayor rapidez y conforme se acerca a
las paredes va a ser un poco menos
rápido de manera que este perfil del
flujo nos va a quedar con una forma
parabólica un gradiente de velocidad en
donde va a ir aumentando cada vez más
conforme se acerque a la parte de
enmedio del tubo y va a ir disminuyendo
conforme se acerque a la parte de abajo
y si queremos conocer cuánto volumen
pasa a través de un punto en esta
tubería cuántos metros cúbicos del
fluido pasan a través de este punto por
unidad de tiempo lo podemos calcular
usando esta fórmula el volumen sobre la
unidad de tiempo metros cúbicos sobre
tiempo y a esta fórmula se le llama
ley de base y nos dice que este volumen
que pasa en un punto durante una unidad
de tiempo va a depender de delta p
multiplicada por pi por ere a la cuarta
dividido entre 8 por eta por l esta es
una ecuación medio extraña vamos a ver
cada una de sus partes para comprenderla
esta es la ley de pase y delta p se
refiere a la diferencia de presiones en
los extremos de la tubería tenemos la
presión de este lado que le llamamos p 1
y la presión de este otro lado que se
llama p
si ambas fueran iguales no habría un
flujo aquí debe haber una diferencia
para que pueda darse el flujo del fluido
en esta tubería si el flujo es hacia la
derecha pero uno debe ser mayor que p 2
y mientras más grande sea esta
diferencia p 1 - p 2 tendremos un mayor
volumen de flujo por unidad de tiempo lo
que tiene sentido y es nuestro factor
geométrico r es el radio de esta tubería
ésta es mi r aquí tenemos un 8 y está ya
lo conocemos
este es el coeficiente de viscosidad de
este fluido el flujo del fluido es
inversamente proporcional a este
coeficiente de viscosidad mientras más
viscoso sea el fluido más se va a
resistir al movimiento o al flujo y
tendremos menos metros cúbicos por
segundo y eso también es inversamente
proporcional a la longitud de la tubería
si la tubería es más
es larga más distancia tendrá que
recorrer este fluido y tendremos menos
volumen por unidad de tiempo en cierto
punto esta es la ley de púas y tiene
muchas aplicaciones para la medicina y
la ingeniería si ustedes quieren conocer
cuál es la tasa de flujo sanguíneo
aunque aquí hay que tener cuidado
estamos suponiendo que este es un fluído
newtoniano significa que ésta no depende
de la velocidad del fluido y también
suponemos que tenemos un buen flujo
laminar el flujo laminar significa que
estas capas de fluido se van a mantener
en su línea no van a estar atravesando
pse entre ellas una vez que tenemos que
se empiezan a atravesar vamos a tener
turbulencias y una vez que tenemos
turbulencia vamos a tener que usar unos
cálculos más complicados para poder
describir la dinámica de esto así que
suponemos que no hay turbulencia y
tenemos un buen fluido newtoniana si ese
es el caso la ley de pase y nos va a
permitir calcular el volumen que pasa
por un punto de la tubería durante
cierta unidad de tiempo